but here's the thing like women are
different we look for different traits
and if a guy makes you like i can't
remember what it is biologically but if
a guy makes you laugh it shows social
status and women you don't you have a
blue check mark
right does that help you get girls
i'll go go i'd like to speak on his
behalf
he doesn't want to answer this question
okay but before before right before you
were dating does that did that help
a blue check mark
i was just saying
basically like he wanted to get blue
checked
and like he had to go through the
process whatever and he said after that
his dms were like heavy like and that's
what i'm saying because women and women
value social status so like historically
if um
mine's dry because men and women
because again men
because men and women are different men
don't do you guys care if a girl is a
check mark no yeah
but but women do because historically
it's it's pretty celebrated
where's my dear
i'm off the market i'm off the map yeah
but i'm saying like like men and women
are different so historically women um
if someone else was had selected the guy
then that showed that he could take care
of other women so that's pre-selection
it's social status sociology baby
that's why i like that
that's that's why it's a double standard
for like men and women like a guy can
have many girls and more girls will want
him but if a guy a girl has many guys
it's like they don't want her i just
think like
but as women i think we need to do
better i think this comes with age
obviously i'm a little bit older than
you guys how old are you 27 um i'm 33.
um now a day older yeah
thank you
um 35 shut up 16.
[Music]
as women i think it does come with age
and stuff like that but like
um for women not to sleep with married
men like or men with
in a relationship if you know do you
know what i mean if it's on your
instagram whatever if it's a secret and
he's acting like i'm single blah blah
blah then okay so as a woman i feel like
we need to stop going i know you're
about to hit me with a stat so just one
second and then um and then as women in
relationships when a man does step out
or gets 100 pounds and we shouldn't
really stay either i think as women we
because we're afraid of a man meaning
if if i cheat i know my shit's going to
be on the front door he doesn't have
that same
stress and fear that we do you know what
i mean so he we have to teach this fear
it's true i know i just see him doing
like he's about to say no but you know
if we if we then change the script of
the fact of if we didn't cheat and we
kept him you know i mean accountable and
had gave them that fear if you knew
that your [ __ ] was going to be on the
front doorstep you would act so
different pattern but can i also say i
think that also depends on the woman so
for example like some women i think
teach their man to kind of
like they allow their man to feel like
they allow their partner sorry to feel
like that a lot of stuff can slide so i
feel like once you condone a lot of
stuff like even the small stuff it does
matter because their mind gets to build
that comfortability with them to think
do you know what i can step out i can do
all of this and it's okay
because i know my woman ain't going
nowhere
i disciplined that but the problem is a
guy has to earn that
where women like women can just cheat
being a girl but like men has to like
it's almost i don't know we just have to
live with these stereotypes that
everyone's complaining about but like
naturally
people go along with like for example
if a woman cheating on a man in a
relationship yeah he's got he might not
exactly
if a guy cheats on a woman there's a lot
of possibilities that you're going to
say regardless that's what i'm saying is
where we have to flip it no of course
we're in this progressive stage that
we're trying to change it but like we're
still living by the same [ __ ] i don't
care what no one says in 2020
girls are still like i'm gonna say girls
but hoes are still acting the same like
there's a lot of [ __ ]
but the problem is like like
if if you can cheat in the girl states
that means you're not easy to replace
because it's harder it's harder for a
girl
no no but i'm saying like like
like the reason girls stay is because
the guy's not replaceable otherwise she
would leave
no i think that's sort of like also
comfortability and feelings that i think
they're like oh i feel like a lot of
women like you can actually be you can
be weak by the fact that like with the
man that you're in love with whereas
with guys i think it's a lot of like
more to do with pride like women can let
a lot of stuff like they can they think
long term they've bigger picture like
you know okay cool but we can work on it
whereas with men it's it's a pride thing
like you really stepped out of me
they will break they will leave the girl
and still be unhappy that they left the
girl but they have to hold it down okay
but do
do you think do you think that cheating
is different for men and women yes
it should have been easier
to talk about the master lock and the
key you want that theory speak up about
women have it easier let me hear it
listen listen come on emcee from nowhere
you know we're like a woman teacher i
like obviously i can't say for all women
in our situation but obviously like
some women like you obviously see it's
in the media or whatever
we may do a madness yeah and it's like
there's always these feelings and all
these raw tartare comes out in a
situation men do it like oh he's a dog
he's this and that but women do like the
same goodness and it's all about or that
they're in a bad situation or their
feelings this mandu on instinct it's sad
it's sad and it's not an ex it's like a
double standard but guys don't like if
they cheat on someone it's not like oh
damn i'm in love with this girl though
it's like you can go back the next day
and it's like this is this is the person
i love it's a woman i love however when
a girl does it like we well
stereotypes or conversation like it's
the emotional part first before it's
like yeah i'm trying to get some like
they'll be like they'll be like is that
is that the thing i know like i'ma ask
i'm
for women as well i feel like it could
be on instincts as well because
in a moment she might just be
like horny yeah and a drunk man out yeah
she could be hauling her girls yeah yeah
in the case she would never be my wife
she could never be my wife if she can be
on a night out and she can retweet
retweet she can be horny on a night out
and she can get chopped she will never
be my girlfriend but a guy can what
about guys
not you but like i could do the same
thing oh yeah so why is that okay in a
men's mentality why is it okay for guys
to think that okay cool i can step out i
can be on a lads night out i can do all
of this and it's okay
but it doesn't make it okay but again
we're biologically different like met
well i mean
i'm the host yeah okay
have you guys ever hooked up with a girl
that was like kind of ugly like you kind
of regretted it the next day
like and it was no feelings it was just
like
that's a yes so unsupported
to be honest like in history like
i've never done one of like regretted
like there's something like
it just looks wise though
no never done
[Music]
but girls don't
but
but i'm saying like
i was just meaning like metaphorically
like
two are you sure yeah are you positive
just like i would say i'd like to say
like a go through a reasonable
level
is it in your notes
but the but the thing is like like women
don't have it like that like if a dude
cheats she just has to be like hot and
there like if a girl cheats he said
that'll be funny and ugly
funny and ugly
no funny funny and ugly guys have to
play the long game that's not
not one night snapping
even with that like i think they get
excited as well like you know you could
give them like a chance and then they
get excited like thinking they actually
like
the chase yeah
no but see with them i think they get
excited like they don't have to keep
chasing like they think once they've got
you let's say a funny and ugly guy chase
like
until he gets me saved back to the
relationship i think he gets too
comfortable and thinks you know what
maybe he's out of my league and i'm like
no like you need to stop being original
like he's on my leash like he's like you
realize you realize men tend to date
hotter and hotter because like again
women value social status so if like
like how many girls creep on the
ex-girlfriend
like see what she looks like but like
women do that as a form of pre-selection
because they'll say that
i'm saying like it's a form of
pre-selection so like if i see that a
guy had this this hot of a girl then a
girl
is that you know what i mean i never
said yo this guy's not hotter than him
so men like like women
tend to like date date down after where
like men tend to like they date up and
because again like women have a long
laundry list of [ __ ] they have to like
that guy has to have in order for them
to sleep with them where men it's like
short hot available there
well i mean loyal like whatever there's
more but like it starts there where
women it starts with like a way bigger
list we'll start with the head council
i suppose women be on these crazy food
was icks on that line women be turned
off online on madison oh yeah i get i
get you took a drink of drink that's
left on the other day i wasn't feeling
your left hand